oh that doesn't look normal
oh no oh boy having trouble urinating
yeah big-time that's cuz you're paying
for to watch oh yeah there's a demon in
that penis oh you need to set him free
wow you need to follow these simple
steps my friends okay
demonic general possession also known as
DGP is no laughing matter we both had it
I had it in high school
and I had it when I was six good news is
though it's very very painful it's also
highly treatable
kans make sure you know what to look out
for here are the warning sign symptom
number one people urination does it burn
when you pee that's because they're
peeing for two there's a demon in your
wiener get that demon out of your waders
[Applause]
fit them to genital burning what your
penis comes into contact in the Bible
sizzle sizzle demon symptom three demon
semen in your undies doctors and pills
won't cure this big pharma doesn't even
want you to know that it exists they
call vaginal possession things like UTIs
an anal possession IBS Crohn's are all
sort of colitis big pharma more like big
pharma but they were all cured using our
one-of-a-kind demon extraction system
Oh out of my wiener come to the trailer
up to the track
[Applause]
our patented rosary beads can remove any
demon from your sex organs in the good
news is when you're done they can be
used as jewelry toys for your kids a
little beads in the best chair of all as
prevention hero ways how to prevent DGP
don't try on swimsuit to the mall
without underwear never use your
genitals to open doors ATMs
both the banking machines and the
ass-to-mouth sex are a sure way to catch
it using a haunted dildo or a secondhand
dildo someone who just passed away
sleeping naked in a haunted hotel don't
have sex with demons and the biggest
thing of all spread awareness talk about
this with your kids your co-workers and
your religious leaders and most
importantly use condoms they'll protect
you from those pesky STDs sexually
transmitted demons penis your O'Neill
condoms do not prevent sexually
transmitted diseases or pregnancy this
ad is brought to you by truth org that's
truth with an e so we don't get sued
[Music]